make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing up
and uh make sure you guys hit the like
button if you enjoy the video and
yeah let's begin
okay so we are getting into the immortal
hulk uh tie-in for the king and black
now for those of you guys who are not
following immortal hulk and i think
we're about one story arc behind
um there's a lot that's happening in
there right so what's really happened
more recently
is that the leader had basically found
out or figured out a way to essentially
tap into
and remove in essence the personalities
of the incredible hulk right so like
double hulk and all those different
versions so devil hulk that personality
has been killed off
uh the mind of bruce banner so like his
consciousness was extracted from the
body of the incredible hulk and so all
we really have right now in the immortal
hulk line of stories
is the savage hulk who's been drained of
a ton of game of radiation so he's
really emaciated and whenever the savage
hulk turns back into banner
it's basically joe fix it hulk who can
essentially controls the body of banner
right so
bruce banner's mind isn't actually there
so whenever we see bruce banner in this
story
it's essentially joe fixit who's walking
around pretending to be banner right but
uh the funny thing about this is this is
one of those comics that we rarely ever
get to see
well we don't have any words whatsoever
instead it's all just
art and it's an awesome idea see these
are the kind of comics that i love right
it's
one of the reasons why you guys like for
king and black one it's definitely a
story you should be buying
but two comments like this are comics
that i would personally buy those you
guys don't really know how i deal with
comics for the most part i only really
buy digitally the only time i ever buy a
physical copy of a comic is if it's of
significance so like i have a physical
copy of giant size x-men number one
uh fantastic four annual number two
which is the original origin of dr doom
i've got uh i think x factor issue
number five which is the first
appearance of apocalypse uh but i only
really buy comics
that are that are like super significant
i only really buy physical versions of
that beyond that i just i just buy them
digitally right because it's infinitely
easier to read all my comics on an ipad
than it is to carry around
like 15 physical comic books right i
mean after all this is 2020
digital is the name of the game at least
for me anyway so one of the cool things
about this
is that what you have here is
essentially like christmas eve more or
less right now this takes place of
course
after null has basically descended on to
on to new york and presumably the rest
of the world but one of the funny things
that's shown here
is is that when we initially saw the
king in black one shot
it basically looks like all was lost
right that like all humanity was
conquered all was lost it was the end of
the day for everybody
what this really points to is the idea
that it's not necessarily all is lost
that a lot of people are in hiding right
a lot of people are kind of retreating
and trying to stay hidden away from
being attacked by null ah but that new
york and of itself in terms of the
heroes that we know have more or less
fallen right and a lot of this comes by
way of a guy who's just making his way
through the street right taking some
presents some different things that he
has
and trying to leave but when he drops
one of these gifts he's suddenly met by
the arrival of
the immortal hulk now again the immortal
hulk is drained of a ton of gamma
radiation and that's why he's not nearly
as huge as he normally is he's still
strong as all get out
like make no mistake he's by no means
like on par with like the average guy
right it's not like you know immortal
hulk versus captain america who's gonna
win an arm wrestling contest
it's not really like that he's still
super strong just not necessarily where
he used to be in terms of all his
abilities and all that kind of stuff but
this guy basically sees him
and is scared out of his wits right he's
just like what in the heck
so he just he takes off running now when
this present drops the immortal hulk
because of the fact that he's basically
a childlike savage beast reacts the way
a child would right like
presents you know and then just goes to
grab it but then suddenly he's met by
the arrival of one of the grindels of
null and this is where things get
interesting now the funny thing about
this is that when it comes to savage
hulk and marvel comics
over the years he's largely been
displayed in a few different ways but
those ways have essentially been limited
right so either you see what is in
essence a child like persona not in so
far as like he acts like a kid
but in the sense that he thinks like a
kid right he thinks in simple terms that
he's not by any means the sharpest tool
in the shed the idea that the savage
hulk
always wanted to be left alone right he
just wanted to live in peace there was a
time and i think it was either doing roy
thomas or bill bantelo or peter david's
runner maybe all three
um where he basically just kind of
wanted to live out in the wilderness on
his own and just be left alone right and
people just kept running up on him and
causing him problems i want to say that
was roy thomas
because that was when the whole arcs
about general thunderbolt ross really
started to take off
in terms of him being a villain for the
immortal hulk but in terms of how he's
shown here which is
a very very childlike person right so
the incredible hulk operating and
thinking on the level of like a four
or a five-year-old is not really
something that we've seen before we
haven't really seen him depicted exactly
in that way and so one of the things
that happens here is of course the
immortal hulk basically ends up grabbing
you know this
this street light post and then just
like beats the crap out of the grendel
symbiote with it
now of course this is by no means going
to stop this thing right i mean
it's just it's not going to work but
what happens in all of this and this is
really a really really cool moment what
happens in all this
is that when the grendel symbiote goes
to seize control of the immortal hulk
to take him over and then bring him into
the fold as being a servant of knoll the
immortal hulk
grabs the the stub where the light posts
used to be and because of the because of
the electricity coursing through it it
goes through him
and then into the grendel which
basically fries the thing to like it
totally incinerates it and so that's
kind of that's that's kind of a cool
thing because
i like this idea that the the savage
hulk is kind of this
childlike lumbering beast that kind of
bumps his way into success
because it still kind of maintains the
nature of the hulk that like that by and
large the incredible hulk was just brute
strength that's all he really was
and there was a kind of element to there
that like the incredible hulk did
whatever the sword he needed him to do
in order to win but a lot of really
really classic and great writers you
know steve englehart even people like
that
focused on the idea that the incredible
hulk despite being childlike and stupid
still had this sort of understanding of
how to utilize the things around him
right now i'm not saying
this child like hulk is like okay hulk
grab electric post
electric post shock grendel hulk escape
like i don't i don't i doubt it was that
line of logic we're not really given any
kind of of
thought pattern here and that's what's
really cool is it gives us the ability
to kind of make it up on our own or at
least reference the immortal hulk as
we go through it but what ends up
happening is that when he opens this
this you know little present that it's
basically just this small little
you know keychain type device that looks
like a whistle of sorts but because of
all the pandemonium and the chaos
that you end up having these uh these
cops show up right now
the incredible hulk consistently wanted
the incredible hulk consistently
untrusted you know not trusted now even
you know especially now in the aftermath
though really everything going on with
the leader the aftermath of the events
of shadow base and all that kind of
stuff
the hulk's like public enemy number one
right like everybody's hunting for this
guy
and so where he points down to the
ground to where the symbiote was but
it's no longer there then like one they
don't really know what to make of it and
two if there was something there to see
it's not there anymore so as far as
they're aware the hulk's just being
crazy like he always is and they
immediately opened fire now of course
this leads to the immortal hulk
basically jumping away
but both of these cops are seized upon
by the grendel symbiote now as the
immortal hole kind of makes his way
through he ends up coming across a place
called mantlos now of course
this is an obvious reference to bill
mantlow kudos to you al ewing for doing
this algorithm is the one who's writing
immortal hulk right now kudos to you man
it's like one of the most prolific
incredible hulk writers in the history
of the comic
if you care about the you know character
dissection right if all you want to do
is see the hulk smash then greg packs
the writer for you but if you care more
about like the interpersonal
relationships of the hulk why he does
what he does
the the whole idea of like psychological
trauma and all that kind of stuff then
bill matlow was kind of the writer for
you from back in the day right bill
mantlow and then peter david who just
kind of continued a lot of the writing
that bill madlow did now the reality is
this story is basically a stand-in for
like fao schwartz just a ridiculously
overpriced and expensive toy store
you'd only ever buy like two things
there right it's just
it's ridiculous kind of a funny story
myself mariah sal
and tiffany and i think ben and ethan
over at counterpop and maybe danielle
um we all met up during the weekend that
myself and i were going to wrestlemania
and we all went to like we went to eat
and went to go shopping in new york we
went to like fao shorts
and it really is just that expensive
right they're really selling products
based on their name
that's really all it is but when the
incredible hulk sees this kind
of of toy set here something akin to
like connects right which is just
mechanics is what it's called here but
when it's something i can to connect
that he kind of has this flashback to
when he was younger and he enjoyed
science
studying things like that and the
abusive nature of his father now
this is a really really great moment and
this is one of the things that i really
really praised al ewing for with his
handling of immortal hulk
because it would have been very easy for
al ewing to be like okay guys i'm
writing immortal hulk and all he's going
to do is just beat stuff up but it's not
really that way
right in the early stories in the early
run of al ewing a lot of it really was
like the bill mantlo peter david's style
of storytelling which was like
psychological trauma different things
like that the one below all basically
appearing is like bruce banner's father
brian banner kind of tormenting him in
that way it was it was kind of wild but
the the whole
theme when it comes to the immortal hulk
is that the psychological trauma he
experienced at the hands of his abusive
father
still reigns supreme right it's still
like the one thing that bruce banner is
the most terrified of and so that's what
makes it kind of intriguing because when
he sees that
he immediately starts lashing out right
like a child he doesn't really
understand his emotions he doesn't
understand what he's feeling and so all
he does is take that lack of
understanding and turn it into
rage right and that's kind of how we as
people are whenever we feel a certain
way but we don't really know how to
interpret our emotions effectively by
using our words
we turn to the most basic primal
instinct which is rage
it's the fight or flight right like our
emotions literally put us in a fight or
flight mode right like it's just
you know i don't know how to handle it
so just fight just just attack you know
just be angry and that's kind of how
that's how you sort of differentiate
between a rational thinking human being
and a person who really is childlike in
nature right a rational human being
would kind of be like okay this is how
i'm feeling how do i interpret this and
then go forward accordingly
a child like human being would just
immediately devolve to like rage and
anger and just lash out at people right
it's what kids do and so because of that
the the immortal hulk
basically kind of transitions back into
banner again now remember this is not
technically bruce banner it's the body
of bruce banner but the mind of bruce
banner is occupied by joe fix it right
the actual mind of bruce banner is just
kind of out there in the ether somewhere
and it's just kind of out there you know
uh taken away by by the leader and doing
its thing and so with that being the
case of course the grindel
manifest now this is something kind of
twisted and something we don't really
normally see that the grindel has
actually
merged both cops into one entity right
so they're like a cinebite from like the
hellraiser movies
the hellraiser books from clyde barker
damn you clyde barker for writing those
books the world is now a darker place
because of because of the fact that
hellraiser was created but this of
course leads to
uh leads to really joe fix it banner
we're just gonna call him banner for the
sake of it oh you know at least him just
kind of
making an escape and trying to figure
out a way to come out on top now this is
one of the big differences
between joe fixit and almost any other
version of the incredible hulk almost
all the other personalities of the hulk
whether he was the horseman war for
apocalypse or
savage hulk or like you know world war
hulk or something like that what warhor
probably would have done this too
uh but one of the big differences is
that joe fix it was a thinker
he was a guy who thought he was by no
means on the same level as banner but he
would basically reason and rationalize
his way out of different situations
that's what made him so dangerous
as it was a man who was exceedingly
strong but was also a guy capable of
intelligent rational thought and so as
the grindel basically follows him
into this toy store he kind of starts
making his way through right this
grinder's kind of slinking along and
it's really
twisted in morbid and really you know
really macabre to be honest with you
guys
but joe fix it and you know really
banners is kind of like okay so like we
buy our time here right like i know how
to take this kind of guy out
something else that's really awesome
here is he's wearing bunny slippers
and those slippers look amazing i would
love to i would love to have some of
those bunny slippers i'd walk
walk around those things like hey oh
yeah look what's going on guys this is
rob
and i've got my bunny slippers on my
feet
it'd be pretty awesome but what he
basically ends up doing and this is this
is
what's so smart what's so cool about
fixit is he plots any schemes and he
basically
lures uh lures these guys into a uh in
front of like a giant speaker system
and then immediately sets the volume to
100 and puts it on blast
and like the sheer just impact of sound
right because remember grindels just
like any other symbiote out there have
an inherent weakness to sound the sheer
impact of sound literally
scatters the grindel symbiote almost all
over the place right it certainly like
takes away from these guys who have
basically been dissolved and absorbed
and that kind of a thing but where it
tries to begin reconstituting itself he
walks around
he literally walks up on him with the
stereotypical makeshift flamethrower a
candle and an aerosol
camp and literally just sprays these
guys down right just phrasing down it's
like yep
business is done like that's that's
pretty much how we do it
when you mess with your fix it you mess
with the best
right i love phrases like that right
like like it would have been cool
like it would have been cool if that if
we got like just that one line at the
end of the comic where he just looks at
him and he's like when you mess with the
bull you get the horns right like
it would have been amazing but of course
this allows you know the the incredible
hulk to kind of revert back into his
childlike form
and literally just start having fun
inside of this toy inside of this toy
store
in all reality i know it's probably not
exactly what you guys were expecting
but if i'm being honest i loved it like
i love this comic right because one the
immortal hulk stories are
already incredibly dark and then two we
kind of get like the the king and black
being an exceedingly dark story
it's kind of nice to see this almost
sort of dark humor going on here i like
it i really enjoyed it so with that
being said guys we're gonna bring this
video to an end
if you are new here to comments explain
make sure you guys hit the sub button to
become part of the rob core if you guys
enjoyed this video
make sure you drop a like and i will
catch you all later
[Music]
peace
do
[Music]
foreign